You might be thinking we're talking about love again,
and your students might look at it and think
We're talking about love again
Well, we're gonna keep talking about love because love is so important
I mean Paul said it in 1st Corinthians, right?
If we have all this stuff if we're this amazing person we can do all these amazing
things
But we don't have love
Then it's all for nothing
So we want to make sure that we talk about love now see at this point you and your
students have walked through
incredible amount of information in fact they're
So much more intelligent and hopefully confident in their conviction for what we as
Christians believe
It's exciting to think when I look back at this book about all the stuff that
they've studied and that you guys have gone
Through it's really really exciting to think back to even just where we started from
But also it's really easy after you've been through all of this
To have so much knowledge crammed into your head and you might have I hope you have
students that are really
Excited to share what has now been crammed in their head and hopefully in ways that
their hearts have been changing and
Incredibly impacted by what you guys have studied over the last several months
that
Instead of
Sharing that sometimes with love
Sometimes we get caught up in trying to be right
Sometimes we get caught up in trying to get notches in our spiritual belt
Sometimes we get caught up in trying just to win the argument and be able to beat
down on somebody else's
beliefs or somebody else's faith and
That's not how we want to do it. So we wanted to make sure that we took time out
to
communicate the idea of
Communicating your faith to others in love and in humility
And that's that can be really difficult to do it can be difficult to train someone
to sit back and actually take the time to listen
And take the time to be interested in what somebody else says to take the time to
really and be just like
Jesus
So that's really what this lesson is all about and we want your students just like
we put inside the introduction activity is
What does it look like?
What does it feel like at a time when they actually experienced love?
We want them to kind of go back into that moment.
So they understand what they felt like
So that they understand how others ought to feel like when they express love of some
kind to another person
So for this week, I'm gonna take you a little bit off script
Maybe for next week as well
But I want you to work on something. I want you to work on role-playing
It's not necessarily what's inside here,
but after kind of walking with you guys through this process
I sat back and thought I really feel like you guys to do some good quality role
playing now
That might be between two students that might be between you and another student or
another adult leader and a student
But the idea here is is as a teachable moment
You want to show students what it looks like to engage in a conversation with
another person in love
But you also want to show students what it looks like to engage another person in
conversation
Without love they need to see both and even if you have two students and one of them
is displaying a something
That's good as they may want to explain something. That's not so good
Don't ridicule them but use this as a teaching moment so that they can see it
because some students are just bent toward
Arguing I've had students over the years that no matter what you do and how you say
they're trying to be loving
But they just want to argue and they just want to win and other students don't want
to argue at all
And they just want to be agreeable and based on different students personalities
they need to see a couple of different things and
So involve as many students as you can get them role-playing a little bit and use
those things as teachable moments
So your students can get a feel for what that looks like and feels like
Before they ever go out into any kind of conversation
But they're going to go out into conversation.
I hope they go out and have conversations but remind them
They're going to mess it up and that's okay. They're gonna come back and go
Oh, I should have said this and oh, I should have said this and oh,
I came off wrong and oh, I said this wrong
Or I I didn't think of this or I forgot that or
It's okay
The fact that they remember those things afterward
Will continue to build their confidence and they'll continue to get better and
better and better just like anything else
This is a skill that has to be developed
But encourage them to continue to use it encourage them and find ways as a group to
get out together
So you can do things together and encourage each other and spur one of and one
another on but make sure your students see
Exactly what love ought to look like and as real of a scenario as you can get
Okay, so small group
Small group time is going to be interesting because what you would you have an
opportunity this time to do is talk with students on
How they can love in different ways maybe in ways that they've never thought of
Depending on the dynamic of the particular group.
They might not be able to think of love in
Particularly terms it'd be another student can think of so students need each other
to balance ideas back and forth
So they can kind of sort of understand how it all will work in their particular
situation
So how one student perceives loving another person is going to be far different than
maybe another student
So use your small group time as a way to kind of open up that conversation to really
Explore on all the different ways that students can connect with other people in a
way that Jesus would
Okay, so last thing
We talk about love
Because the love is what builds relationships
Please remember that it is so important to build
relationships
Make sure your students understand
That this is not about getting conversions. This is about building relationships
Jesus says said to his disciples that it's by your love and by the way you treat one
another that don't know who that you are
My disciples that they'll know who I am
The way in which we love other people is how some people are only ever going to see
Jesus
Don't focus on the conversions
Focus on the relationships and focus on the ways in which we can love others